hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
die ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut ich
habe mir gedacht wir müssen mal wieder
geilen content liefern und habe deswegen
ein neues projekt gestartet bzw
das hier ist heute das erste video dazu
ich bin natürlich so auch nicht der
erste der das versucht oder umsetzt aber
schon so in dem umfang ich hab nämlich
auf ebay für 500 euro ihr könnt euch
vielleicht daran erinnern ich habe schon
mal für 550 euro soll apple paket
gekauft da waren dann glaube ich
insgesamt acht produkte drin hier super
gerne nochmal das kastell eingeblendet
wenn ihr das schon nicht gesehen habt
schickt das gerne mag man muss sagen das
war schon eher ein flop also da habe ich
so ein bisschen - gemacht ich habe
allerdings oft videos gesehen wo leute
defekte iphones reparieren und die dann
verkaufen deswegen habe ich diesmal ist
für 500 euro ein paket bestellt und zwar
mit mindestens zehn iphones das problem
ist natürlich hört sich erst mal viel an
viele davon werden als defekt bzw als
ersatzteillager verkauft hat sind hoffe
ich dass ich diese eventuell reparieren
kann man muss sagen das können iphones
von jedem typ sein ganz kurzes video ich
bin gerade in meiner wohnung und ich
werde jetzt das hier bestellen
restposten lager waren mit mindestens
zehn gebrauchten iphones wir haben ja
auf jeden fall schon mal ein iphone 6
plus glaube ich dann haben wir hier ein
iphone
die meisten geräte werden als defekt
oder als ersatzteile verkauft leider ist
auf der bildschirm oder die software
beschädigt einige geräte weisen
allerdings nur kleinere gebrauchsspuren
vielleicht gestellt ich auch noch ein
anderes paket bzw einzelne iphones für
dieses projekt ich weiß es nicht genau
aber das wäre das erst mal bestellt und
der plan ist dann die iphones alle
fertig zu machen und dann weiter zu
verkaufen und zu schauen ob man da plus
machen kann aber das hab ich euch
wahrscheinlich auch schon gerade erklärt
sprich wir können auch einen defekt des
iphone 12 pro max so wenig ist aktuell
haben da drin haben tauschen den
bildschirm aus und verstärken ist dann
für 600 euro was ich natürlich nicht
glaube aber theoretisch könnte das sein
das paket steht genau hier und wir
machen es jetzt mal auch ich bin
gespannt weil moment im nächsten wird
dann natürlich folgendes passieren dass
ich zusammen mit einem kollegen diese
iphones repariere und wir sie verkaufen
und dann schauen wir mal ob diese 500
euro aufstocken können vielleicht stelle
ich mir das alles auch zu einfach vor
aber wenn er nicht
der restposten youtuber anlagenbauer an
wo ist jetzt wie ein messer ich denke
das ist okay wenn wir das ist so machen
alles klar
dann starten war mal rein wir haben hier
oben direkt ein paket drin also in
diesem paket sind zwei extra paket ich
denke mal hier sind die guten sachen
drin und dann noch eine menge zerstörte
iphones also manche sehen davon wirklich
ganz übel aus aber die schauen wir uns
gleich alle ein bisschen genauer an
wir machen jetzt erstmal hier das geile
auf ok kommen sagt apple iphone x64
gigabyte silber effekt scheiße leute ich
zeige es euch so wie es ist hier und
steht drauf reklamation lautsprecher
defekt mikrofon defekt vibrationen
defekt hengst moralisch also ja wenn der
das schon darauf geschrieben hat denke
ich mal dass das sinn aber leute guck
mal wenn wir das so jemand in die hand
drücken würde
es sieht ja wirklich das hat absolut
keine gebrauchsspuren es plakat ein
bisschen als hätte das schon mal jemand
versucht aufzumachen aber gut also das
sind schon mal die fehler von diesen
dingen trotzdem habe ich hier ein iphone
x64 gb was kostet so etwas neu safe ja
noch die 100 euro oder ich mach das mal
an weil wahrscheinlich angehen tut es ja
wohl oder weil leute gucken wir hier das
dingen geht an das ist ja schon mal ein
gutes zeichen und ich denke vielleicht
im kammern das noch reparieren das
wässern eis für dieses projekt wir
wissen es nicht ich will mich jetzt auch
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster lehnen
schauen wir einfach mal was wir noch so
in diesem paket haben ein weiteres paket
wenn ich mal zur seite wir widmen uns
jetzt erstmal den anderen sache hier
habe ich gerade gesehen haben wir glaube
ich sechster sind das netz gebt euch mal
dieses handy leute dass es komplett
brook also was auch immer der besitzer
damit gemacht hat er muss auf jeden fall
ein neues display drau und dann haben
wir hier auch noch eins wo auch auf
jeden fall neues display traut
vorausgesetzt es geht überhaupt noch an
und dieses hier alter wie kann man ein
bisschen mit seinem handy so um den
körper das ist sogar gebogen ach du
scheiße man also ich denke mal mit
diesem geborgen
kann ich absolut nichts mehr anfangen
wobei schauen wir einfach mal also jeder
safe sehen im zweiten part werden die
ganzen sachen aufbereitet und dann halt
im besten fall auch direkt mit verkaufen
dann schauen wir wie für gewinnen wir
machen können ist ja auch denk ich mal
interessant für die meisten von euch
seid ihr nicht wisst wie man gerade
reich wird alex zeige es euch auf jeden
fall aktuell nicht mit meinen youtube
klicks leute dieses dieses ding habe ich
gerade an gemacht da ist es auch noch 41
jetzt seht ihr tacchelli kann auf diesem
iphone nicht aktiviert werden
zum entsperren home taste drücken
home-taste perfekt okay man naja hab
müssen wegen der lösung finden und
dieses hier ich guck mal ich schließe
das mal an ich habe mir extra ganz viele
ladekabel hier mit hingenommen und wir
schauen mal ob dieses gerät angeht 31 ja
es lädt okay das ist schon mal gut man
muss halt nur bei allen geräten schauen
lohnt sich das wenn man ersatzteile
kaufen wenn man die überhaupt noch
bekommt dann noch drauf zu bauen
irgendwo ist dann wahrscheinlich auch
eine grenze überschritten und das lohnt
sich einfach nicht meinen dass wir den
grund haben warum diese ganzen sachen
jetzt verkauft wurden aber immerhin
halten 500 euro also die will ich auf
jeden fall wieder reinholen okay dann
haben wir hier noch zwei iphone 5 es war
das kann ich mir nicht angucken da
kriegt man ja wirklich gebt euch mal
wieder vogel hier seine diese
displayschutzfolie darauf gezogen hat
hier oben an den rändern da kriegt man
wirklich gänsehaut die muss ich erst mal
direkt abreißen das geht ja nicht mehr
ach du scheiße diese displayschutzfolie
ist einfach mit dem iphone display 1
geworden über die zeit
okay das sind zwei junge also für alle
die noch nie ein iphone von innen
gesehen haben so sieht's aus eigentlich
ziemlich unspektakulär doch du scheiße
ich glaube die kann man direkt auf eine
sperre bewerten nicht sperma erleichtert
also sowas habe ich noch nicht gesehen
wenn man ein gebrauchtes iphone 5 s
verkaufen möchte kann man froh sein wenn
man noch 40 50 euro bekommt und diese
hier sind ein absolut katastrophalen
zustand weswegen ich da sehr sehr
geringe hoffnung einsätze trotzdem legen
wir sie mal zur seite und machen weiter
mit einem paket was glaube ich ganz gut
aussieht wobei es ist schon so die frage
warum werden die hier gar nicht
gepolstert
für einen transport halt das ist ja erst
mal kein gutes zeichen
haben die jungen mann nicht wahr als er
glück mal der typ ist auf jeden fall
auch phänomenal damit umgegangen
das ist hier hinten richtig raus
gesplittet iphone 8 haben wir hier ich
habe ein echt keinen plan wie man sowas
reparieren sollte also da brauche ich
professionelle hilfe könnte das selber
nicht also das komplette gehäuse ist
eigentlich komplett
aber es ist ein iphone 8 das ist schon
mal gut dann haben wir hier noch ein
iphone lieben denkmal genau zusammen mit
einer hülle die ich jetzt mal schnell ab
mache hier guck mal hinten weil der
hülle kann man einfach hier kannst du
deinen kleingeld reinpacken wenn ich mir
das jetzt so genauer anschaue ihr könnt
das hier auch sehen das iphone 7 hat im
schon ziemlich viele macken also das ist
bestimmt 124 mal hin geklatscht und
nicht nur ein bisschen ach du scheiße da
fragt man sich immer wie so etwas
passiert das kann ja nicht von einmal
hinfallen passieren dass diese ganze
seite so komplett vermarktet ist und
hier haben wir noch ein iphone 6 plus
genau aber ich schlecht ich hatte auch
mal so ein dingen in gold hatte ich das
ist glaube ich roségold und dann haben
wir hier jetzt noch das letzte paket ich
hoffe mal wir haben hier jetzt rächt
sich also noch ein phönix wär schon was
aber iphone elf wäre natürlich noch
besser und es ist ein iphone 8 oder
iphone 8 in schwarz 64 gb das gute ist
die verpackung ist noch mit buy und das
machen wir jetzt mal schnell auf kommt
heraus kein okay
das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut und
hier kann man auf dem russen sogar
kopfhörer mit buy und ihr könnt sehen
dieses handy ist auch in einem sehr
guten zustand wird mal hier display
perfekte ist eigentlich keine einzige
schramme drauf ich hoffe mal das geht an
das wäre auf jeden fall ganz gut bewegen
würde gern wir trainieren musste sich
aufladen
es geht an nice alter ich muss sagen
leute wir haben hier schon mal ein
iphone 8 was funktioniert wir haben hier
zwei von sechs es die beide
funktionieren wo man den display
austauschen muss wir haben hier ein
iphone 7 moment dann haben wir hier noch
ein iphone 8 was ebenfalls glaube ich an
geht oder das habe ich noch gar nicht
getestet bitte hier an
ja auch das geht an leute als ok also
ich freue mich schon ich hoffe gut ich
will nicht zu euphorisch sein und wir
haben hier geiler
wir sind natürlich auch noch das iphone
ist was ebenfalls angeht was man ein
bisschen reparieren muss aber schauen
wir mal
und ja diese anderen hier nicht das weiß
ich noch gar nicht dass ich mal kurz zu
checken oder man es wird auf jeden fall
ein kleines projekt und ich stecke jetzt
mal alle einmal durch dann gibt es ein
kleines update von mir und dann und dann
werde ich mich daran setzen die ganzen
iphones bestmöglich für reparieren zu
reparieren lassen und dann schauen wir
mal wo wir geld technisch land wir sehen
uns gleich wieder dieses rief erwische
produkte verkaufen macht mich das
behindert etwas krenz ich habe jetzt mal
alles ausgewertet wir haben da hinten
haben wir jetzt vier problemkinder da
haben wir sechs handys lee soweit auf
jeden fall in ordnung scheint auch und
eine sache die ich noch vergessen hab
ich bekomme noch ein iphone 7 was er
vergessen hat irgendwie da rein zu tun
und er war so nett meinte er ich hab das
vergessen ich schick dir das doch nach
das gehört eigentlich auch dass es geht
wir haben schon den nächsten tag aber
ich habe gesagt ein ei phone 7 kommen
noch an
das haben wir auch das sollte auf jeden
fall morgen ankommen wir schauen uns
jetzt einmal die handys an ich finde ihr
euch ab ihr sitzt jetzt hier einmal dass
er auch super will ich bin zweiten part
damit wir das dann vergleichen können
wenn ich die so ein bisschen auf wert
oder halt aufwerten lassen weil ich muss
ehrlich sein ich versuche das dann auch
professionell zum teil reparieren zu
lassen damit ich die wirklich über
meinen shop lucky donkey als wie völlig
wieder aufbereitet verkaufen kann
natürlich nur wenn die wirklich einem
geilen zustand sind trotzdem natürlich
auch zu fernreisen dass da niemand
irgendwie abgezogen wird dass ich
vielleicht ein bisschen plus mache dass
der ein oder andere von euch werden neue
stanley suchten schnapper machen kann
also das ist natürlich so der traum
wunsch wir schauen uns einmal noch kurz
hier
diese handys an ich fühle mich dass man
immer hier eben ab wir haben hier oben
einmal das iphone 6 ist das geht leider
nicht an also es lädt hier kommt dann
auch dieser ladebalken aber ist fährt
halt nicht wo das gleiche haben wir hier
noch mit dem 5 es das geld gar nicht an
aber das habe ich mir schon gedacht und
die handys die ich eben schon mal
eingebildet habe funktionieren
eigentlich alles soweit natürlich zum
teil mit macken oder kleinen fehlern
aber wenn ich allein diese sechs plus
noch das iphone 7 was noch dazukommt
verkauft bekomme dann habe ich
eigentlich glaube ich schon kann das
sein dass man da ein bisschen was mit
verdienen kann ich hab natürlich nicht
die größten ansprüche trotzdem hoffe ich
dass es euch gefallen hat dass der bock
haben auf den zweiten part und das sehr
gespannt seit deswegen abonniert super
guernica ich werde das alles mit filmen
wie wir das reparieren und so weiter und
schickt dann ab und zu mal lucky donkey
ab weil da werden ja
verkauft leute danke fürs zuschauen
daumen nach oben während räumchen haut
rein
hier haben wir noch ein iphone x64 gb
von meinem kollegen auf jeden fall auch
sehr leisten und das ist hier leider
komplett raus gesplittet es geht aber an
und das ist das wichtigste ich bin
gerade nackt deswegen zeige ich mich
jetzt nicht aber wenn ich die beiden
rapper ich bin gerade ich bin gerade
halbnackt deswegen ziehe ich mich jetzt
nicht aber wenn ich das hier reparieren
juli dann läuft aber wie am schnürchen
hier